HE’S READY FOR A RALLY IN NEVADA
A LITTLE LATER.
I’M JUDGE JEANINE PIRRO.
THE PRESIDENT CRISSCROSSING THE
COUNTRY WITH THE ELECTION JUST
OVER 50 DAYS AWAY.
I HAD THE HONOR OF VISITING THE
WHITE HOUSE AND SITTING DOWN
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES FOR AN EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW ON THE ROSE GARDEN
PATIO.
JOE BIDEN INDICATED AFTER THE
WOODWARD INFORMATION CAME OUT,
THAT YOUR HANDLING OF THE
CORONAVIRUS AND THAT SITUATION
WAS DESPICABLE AND ALMOST
CRIMINAL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: I THINK A
STATEMENT LIKE THAT IS CRIMINAL.
WE DID A MUCH BETTER JOB THAN HE
COULD HAVE DONE.
IT WAS MUCH LATER THAT HE
THOUGHT THE BAN WAS A GOOD
THING.
WHAT I SAID TO WOODWARD WAS
GOOD.
I SAID CALM, WE DON’T NEED
PANIC.
DO YOU WANT ME TO JUMP UP AND
DOWN AND SAY IS EVERYONE GOING
TO DIE?
I’M A CHEERLEADER FOR THE
COUNTRY.
THAT WAS DONE AFTER I HAD BANNED
CHINA FROM COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY.
I TOOK TREMENDOUS STEPS,
EVERYBODY KNEW HOW I FEEL.
WE SAVED HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF LIVES WITH EACH ONE OF THOSE
BANS AND SAVED 2 TO 2.5 MILLION
LIVES BY DOING WHAT WHEN DID
EARLY.
JUDGE JEANINE: YOU ARE SAYING
YOUR TIMING IS GOOD.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT BOB WARD
WARD’S TIMING.
HE WAITED UNTIL SEPTEMBER 7
MONTHS LATER TO ANNOUNCE TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC HOW DANGEROUS HE
SAID IT WAS.
WAS HIS TIMING GOOD?
DWTPRESIDENT TRUMP: HE’S AN
OPPORTUNIST.
NOT A BAD GUY.
HE WROTE THINGS THAT ARE FALSE
AND UNTRUE.
I SAID LET ME DO -- I TOOK 16
PHONE CALLS AND WE HAD GOOD
CONVERSATIONS, NOT LONG, BUT
GOOD CONVERSATIONS.
I DON’T KNOW IF THE BOOK IS GOOD
OR BAD.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU I SAID DON’T
PANIC.
THE PRESS WILL MAKE EVERYTHING
LOOK BAD BECAUSE IT’S THE FAKE
NEWS.
THAT’S THE 85%.
BUT I DISCUSSED WITH HIM LOTS OF
DIFFERENT THINGS.
I THINK THEY WERE GOOD
DISCUSSIONS.
WE’LL SEE HOW IT COMES OUT.
ON THIS SUBJECT IF YOU LOOK, IF
HE NOT IT WAS WRONG, THEN HE
SHOULD HAVE REPORTED IT EARLY.
IF LIVES WERE GOING TO BE LOST
BE HE SHOULD HAVE REPORTED IT
EARLY.
HE DIDN’T THINK THERE WAS
ANYTHING WRONG WITH IT.
IT’S SURPRISING THE PRESS DIDN’T
PICK IT UP.
JUDGE JEANINE: WHEN HE CALLED
YOU IN MARCH YOU SAID I DIDN’T
WANT TO CAUSE PANIC.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: LOOK AT THE
GREAT LEADERS OF THE WORLD.
WINSTON CHURCHILL STOOD ON THE
ROOFTOPS OF HOUSES IN LONDON
MAKING SPEECHES.
YOU WANT CALMNESS, YOU DON’T
WANT SOMEBODY JUMPING UP AND
DOWN SAYING THIS IS TERRIBLE.
WE WANT STRENGTH AND LEADERSHIP
AND WE DON’T WANT PANIC.
JUDGE JEANINE: JOE BIDEN AND
KAMALA HARRIS.
THE ACCEPTANCE OF THE VACCINE IS
PRETTY MUCH GOING ALONG
POLITICAL LINES.
DEMOCRATS DON’T WANT TO TRUST IT
OR RECEIVE IT BECAUSE IT’S
COMING OUT OF YOUR
ADMINISTRATION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THEY DON’T WANT
IT BECAUSE THEY ARE AFRAID IT
WILL MAKE ME LOOK GOOD.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PLASMA AND
THE THINGS WE HAVE COME OUT WITH
ALREADY, THE NUMBER, 83% BETTER
IN TERMS OF FATALITIES.
WE ARE REALLY ROUNDING THE
CORNER.
THIS IS WITHOUT ANYTHING FURTHER
THAN WE ALREADY HAVE.
AND WE HAVE GOOD THINGS OUT
THERE ALREADY IN TERMS OF -- I
WOULD SAY YOU CAN’T USE THE WORD
CURE YET.
BUT PRETTY CLOSE TO A CURE.
THE VACCINE ITSELF, IT COME COME
OUT IN OCTOBER.
BUT WHETHER IT’S OCTOBER,
NOVEMBER, DECEMBER.
IT WILL COME OUT SOON.
WE HAVE GREAT COMPANIES, THEY
ARE ADVANCED AND THE RESULTS
WILL BE GOOD.
JUDGE JEANINE: THE NUMBERS ARE
GOING DOWN.
THERE IS A QUESTION WHETHER THE
LOCKDOWN WORKS AND IF PEOPLE
NEED TO GET OUTSIDE.
JOE BIDEN IS SAYING ON THE
ADVICE OF THE SCIENTISTS I WOULD
SHUT IT DOWN AGAIN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THAT WOULD BE A
DISASTER.
THE JOB NUMBERS, WE ARE SETTING
RECORDS BY MILLIONS OF JOBS.
THE COUNTRY IS COMING BACK.
IT’S A SUPER V.
RETAIL SALES ARE BEYOND ANY
NUMBER THEY WERE EVER AT.
WE ARE DOING NUMBERS NOW AS WE
ARE ROUNDING I THINK THE FINAL
TURN.
WITH OR WITHOUT, HAVING THE
VACCINE IS GREAT.
IT WILL HAPPEN SOON.
IT COULD HAPPEN IN OCTOBER.
BUT WE ARE ROUNDING THE TURN ON
THE VIRUS.
THEY HAVE TO OPEN UP.
IT’S ONLY THE DEMOCRATS WHO ARE
CLOSED.
IN MY OPINION THEY ARE CLOSED
FOR POLITICAL REASONS.
NORTH CAROLINA, MICHIGAN, NEW
YORK, LOOK AT WHAT THEY ARE
DOING IN NEW YORK.
THE POOR CITIES WITH THE
RESTAURANTS.
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE TO NEW YORK,
AND PEOPLE ARE LEAVING, IS
DISGRACEFUL.
BETWEEN CUOMO AND DEBLASIO.
COMING FROM NEW YORK, IT’S A
VERY SAD THING TO WITNESS.
BUT WE HAVE TO OPEN UP OUR
STATES.
THEY ARE KEEPING THEM CLOSED
BECAUSE ON NOVEMBER 3 THEY WANT
THE NUMBER TO BE AS BAD AS
POSSIBLE.
BASED ON THE NUMBERS YOU ARE
SEEING, PROBABLY IT WOULD BE
BETTER IF THESE STATES WERE
OPEN.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE INSIDE THOSE
LOCK DOWNS, THEY ARE SUFFERING
BETWEEN DEPRESSION, LOSING THEIR
JOBS, DRUGS, ALCOHOL, ALL THE
THINGS HAPPENING TO THOSE
PEOPLE.
THAT’S CAUSING MUCH MORE DAMAGE
THAN THE VIRUS ITSELF.
JUDGE JEANINE: YOU MENTIONED
NORTH CAROLINA.
VOTING ALREADY STARTED AND THEY
ARE ON LOCKDOWN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: I WANT PEOPLE
TO GO OUT AND VOTE.
YOU HAVE SOLICITED AND
UNSOLICITED.
IN THE COUNTRY 80 MILLION
UNSOLICITED -- PEOPLE WHO DON’T
EVEN KNOW WHAT A BALLOT IS, HERE
COMES A BALLOT.
SUPPOSEDLY THEY ARE NOT SENDING
THEM TO REPUBLICAN NEIGHBORHOOD
OR SPOADSING THE PEOPLE AREN’T
GIVING THEM BACK OR THEY GO OUT
AND HARVEST THEM.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS SEEM TO DO
THAT.
THEY PLAYED THAT GAME FOR A LONG
TIME.
JUDGE JEANINE: I PROSECUTED
THOSE CASES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THE FACT IS,
THEY ARE PLAYING VERY DIRTY.
80 MILLION BALLOTS.
WE NEVER HAD A NUMBER ANYWHERE
CLOSE TO THAT.
YOU WILL SEE A MESS ON ELECTION
NIGHT THAT’S GOING TO BE
LEGENDARY.
ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS SAY GO
OUT AND VOTE OR REQUEST A
BALLOT.
OR ABSENTEE.
GET AN ABSENTEE BALLOT.
WHEN YOU REQUEST IT, IT COMES TO
YOU AND YOU VOTE AND YOU SEND IT
BACK.
BUT THEY ARE JUST SENDING OUT 80
MILLION BALLOTS.
JUDGE JEANINE: THEY ARE GENERIC.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE MOVED, A
LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE DIED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THEY DON’T WANT
TO HAVE SIGNATURES VERIFIED.
WHO IS SENDING THEM BACK?
IT’S SO UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
IT’S SO DIS -- IT’S SO
DISHONEST.
WE ARE IN MANY, MANY COURTS
RIGHT NOW AND HOPEFULLY THE
COURTS WILL DECIDE.
IF THEY DON’T, YOU WILL HAVE ONE
HELL OF A MESS ON ELECTION
NIGHT.
JUDGE JEANINE: ON THE ISSUE OF
LAW AND ORDER.
WHEN YOU RAN IN -- IN 2016, YOU
WERE A LAW AND ORDER CANDIDATE.
WE HAVE ANARCHY IN THE STREETS.
WE HAVE TOWNS RUN BY AND STATES
RUN BY DEMOCRAT GOVERNORS AND
MAYORS WHO ARE REFUSING TO ALLOW
THE NATIONAL GUARD TO COME IN.
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THOSE CITIES
AND STATES WHO WANT ORDER TO
COME IN.
BUT THEY CAN’T COME IN NEWS
REQUEST THEIR HELP.
LET’S SAY THEY ARE GOING TO
THREATEN RIOTS IF THEY LOSE ON
ELECTION TONIGHT.
SO WE WIN ON ELECTION NIGHT.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: WE’LL PUT THEM
DOWN VERY QUICKLY.
IT’S CALLED INSURRECTION.
I WOULD RATHER NOTE DO THAT
BECAUSE THERE IS NO REASON FOR
IT.
BUT IF WE DID WE WOULD PUT IT
DOWN WITHIN MINUTES.
MINNEAPOLIS THEY WERE HAVING
PROBLEMS.
WE SENT IN THE NATIONAL GUARD,
IT ALL WENT AWAY.
LOOK AT KENOSHA.
THE SHERIFF, THE POLICE CHIEF,
EAR ALL ON MY SIDE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY IS ON MY SIDE.
EVEN WITH THE HORRIBLE THINGS
GOING ON IN NEW YORK AND
CHICAGO, ALL RUN BY DEMOCRATS.
EVERYTHING WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
IS RUN BY DEMOCRATS.
IT’S ALL RUN BY DEMOCRATS.
EVEN THE POLICE CHIEFS, THEY ARE
ALL QUITTING ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
I THINK I SAW 15 OR 20.
EVERY SINGLE ONE IS FROM A
DEMOCRACY.
BEFORE CHINA SENT US THE PLAGUE,
WE HAD THE BEST CRIME NUMBERS IN
HISTORY.
WHEN THE PLAGUE CAME IT CHANGED
THINGS.
ALL OF THE PROBLEMS ARE IN
DEMOCRAT-RUN CITIES.
THEY ARE BADLY RUN.
THE TAXES ARE TOO MUCH.
BIDEN IS ALL IN THAT.
HE HASN’T STILL TO THIS DAY USED
THE TERM LAW AND ORDER.
HE WOULD LOSE THE RADICAL LEFT
SUPPORTERS HE’S GOT IF THEY SHOW
UP FOR HIM.
THERE IS A QUESTION WHETHER THEY
WILL SHOW UP.
BUT THEY DON’T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT LAW AND ORDER.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE LIVING
IN THE SUBURBS.
I ENDED A REGULATION WHERE LOW
INCOME HOUSING HAS BEEN FORCED
INTO THE SUBURBS.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR A
LONG TIME.
ESPECIALLY UNDER BIDEN AND
OBAMA.
I ENDED IT, I TERMINATED IT.
IT’S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN
ANYMORE.
SO THE SUBURBS ARE NOT GOING TO
HAVE THESE PROJECTS FORCED INTO
THEM.
WHO IN THE SUBURBS IS NOT GOING
TO VOTE FOR ME.
THEY ARE PUTTING CORY BOOKER IN
IN CHARGE.
ONE OF THE MOST LIBERAL.
HE WILL BE IN CHARGE OF BUILDING
PROJECTS IN THE SUBURBS.
IT’S ALREADY HAPPENING.
THEY TAKE OVER THE ZONING AND
THEY FORCE PROJECTS.
JUDGE JEANINE: CITIES ARE BEING
DESTROYED.
THE COMBINATION OF LAWLESSNESS,
AND NOW THE SUBURBS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THE SUBURBS
WILL BE NEXT.
THEY ARE NOT PROTESTERS.
THEY ARE ANARCHIST, AGITATORS
AND RIOTERS.
THEY ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE PAID.
AND PEOPLE WE ARE LOOK AT RIGHT
NOW, WE ARE LOOKING AT THEM
RIGHT NOW.
JUDGE JEANINE: CAN YOU TELL ME?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: NOT YET.
THEY ARE STUPID PEOPLE, TOO.
BECAUSE THEY WILL BE OVERTHROWN
AS SOON AS THEY GET THEIR WISH.
THESE ARE SUPER LIBERAL PEOPLE
THAT HAVE MONEY, AND THEY ARE
HELPING THESE ANARCHISTS AND
THEY ARE JAJ DAY TOWARDS AND
THEY ARE DANGEROUS.
YOU SEE THEM WALK UP TO A
RESTAURANT AND TWO ELDERLY
PEOPLE HAVING DINNER AT A
RESTAURANT AND THEY TAKE A STEAK
AND THE POTATO AND EAT IT?
JUDGE JEANINE: NOW YOU ARE
WAITING TO BE ASKED IN.
WHEN DOES THAT CHANGE?
WHEN DO YOU CROSS THE RUBICON.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: IN KENOSHA THEY
ASKED ME, AND WE DID A JOB LIKE
YOU HAVEN’T SEEN BEFORE.
UNLESS YOU DO AN INSURRECTION,
IT’S NOT BIG ENOUGH FOR
INSURRECTION.
I WOULD BE WILLING TO DO IT IN A
HEARTBEAT IF WE NEED IT.
WE DON’T NEED IT.
OUR NATIONAL GUARD IS SO TOUGH.
POLICE DEPARTMENTS, IN SEATTLE
THEY SOLVED THE PROBLEM BEFORE
WE GOT THERE.
THEY HEARD WE WERE COMING IN.
JUDGE JEANINE: TED EXEELER’S
NUMBERS -- TED WHEELER’S NUMBERS
IN POARLD,.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THEY ARE A
DISASTER.
IF HE WOULD SAY COME INTO
PORTLAND.
WE WOULD IN A HEARTBEAT.
THE GOVERNOR HAS GOTTEN CLOSER.
I SPOKE TO THE GOVERNOR.
THEY ARE ARRESTING A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
WE SENT IN THE U.S. MARSHALS FOR
THE KILLER WHO SHOT THE YOUNG
MAN ON THE STREET.
COLD BLOOD K KILLED HIM.
HE DIDN’T LIKE HIS HAT OR
SOMETHING.
IT WASN’T A TRUMP HAT.
IT WAS A RELIGIOUS HAT.
AND HE SHOT HIM COLD BLOOD.
2 1/2 DAYS WENT BY.
I PUT OUT WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO
GO GET HIM.
THE U.S. MARSHALS WENT IN TO GET
HIM AND THEY ENDED IN A
GUNFIGHT.
HE WAS A VIOLENT CRIMINAL AND
THE U.S. MARSHALS KILLED HIM.
THERE HAS TO BE RETRIBUTION WHEN
YOU HAVE CRIME LIKE THIS.
THERE CAN’T BE GUYS STANDING UP
WHO WANT TO FIGHT.
JUDGE JEANINE: THE PROBLEM,
MR. PRESIDENT, THERE ARE
PROSECUTORS WHO ARE NOT
PROSECUTING THE PROTESTERS.
SOCIALISTS ARE ELECTING PEOPLE
LIKE I USED TO PROSECUTE CRIMES.
THEY ARE LETTING THEM GO.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THIS IS A
SHAME.
YOU WILL HAVE A BACKLASH LIKE
YOU HAVE NEVER SEEN.
YOU HAVE SMART, TOUGH PEOPLE WHO
AREN’T GOING TO TAKE IT ANYMORE.